Speaking of debris.
Speaking of debris,
uh,
there was this asteroid that collided with Earth,
over,
uh,
[inaudible] in the Soviet Union in Russia,
sorry,
uh,
just near the Siberia in the euro mountains just on the coast of Siberia than
the border of Siberia that was visible to everybody in broad daylight and he had
to like avert your eyes when it happened and they felt a shock wave and the
shockwave broke windows and sent 600 people,
nearly a thousand people to the hospital.
What happened?
Well,
because they saw the light and they can't,
they got up from their table and went to the window to see what had happened.
There's a time delay between the shockwave and the light because light travels
fast and s sound travel slow.
So we'll go to the windows in the shockwave hits and it blasts broken glass into
their face.
So there's a big bandaid collision that we had people all needed basically
bandaids.
Okay.
No one died,
but nearly a thousand people were injured.
So at an auction,
but that actually exploded and pieces of it were recovered at an auction.
I purchased a piece of that media.
Right.
But you can also purchase
some of the shards of glass that the shockwave had broken.
What do you do with this shit?
I've got it.
It's just a habit.
I'm a part of.
It is a shot across our bow.
That's what that dough and died.
But it's a warning.
There's no better way to a warrant then to have a bandaid cover your injuries
that could of vaporized you or rendered your species extinct.
What's crazy is the ones that don't even make impact,
it's still do devastating damage.
Yes.
Now it didn't,
that one didn't even touch earth.
Right.
It incinerate a 10,000 square kilometers of forest.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
So February 15th,
2013 and uh,
there is a half a ton that people rock was a thousand pounds.
Oh yeah.
That's just a piece that made it through.
Is it iron or the actual piece would have been a about the size of this room.
So a small home.
Wow.
So,
but yeah,
that's amazing that,
that small rock go back up to that again.
Please look at the size of that.
That's not that.
No,
no.
That's what's left over most of it.
It's a vaporized on that,
on the explosion as it came through the atmos.
Right,
but they're saying that that piece of it weighs a thousand pounds a,
do they give it the weight of it over a half ton?
Yeah.
Oh,
we have to,
yeah,
a thousand pounds.
That's crazy.
That rock.
Is that fucking heavy?
Yes.
So,
so the solid,
yes.
Well,
I,
I have to read that to know for sure,
but I think it was an iron meteorite.
I have a knife that was made out of a piece of media or as do I though the
beautiful,
oh yeah.
It's a kitchen knife that I use.
Oh,
see I,
mine is like a,
it's like a crocodile Dundee knife.
Ooh.
Yeah.
That's not a knife.
That's the knife.
But it's waiting.
I want to make a or get someone to make a handle for it.
It's just the,
it's just a metal that would be a four.
It's a forged metal with the glade,
but then you get a pearl handle attached to the base of,
yeah,
so it's a handle.
This UN un,
it's an unadorned piece of metal that would become a,
you know,
a knife.
Oh yes.
Completely sharpened.
Oh yeah.
Where's the fucking handle?
There is the metal hand.
Have you ever seen knight a kitchen?
Knives?
The metal goes all the way down down the center of the handle and you'd see
you'd screw wooden handles on the side.
So you just need the wooden,
I just need the wood or the or the,
if I'm patent they would be Pearl,
you know?
Yeah.
We're all handed revolver.
Pearl pistol.
Yeah.
So yeah,
it's a part of history and it's a reminder that if you want to think about the
future of civilization,
you have to include a defense plan against asteroids,
the dinosaurs,
dinosaurs.
I bet if they could,
they would have had a space program to not go extinct.
No Shit.
I'm thinking now,
is there anything that we're doing now other than occasionally looking up?
Yeah,
we're looking at with monitoring and cataloging them.
Yeah.
But we don't really know what to do.
The day would come,
well we know what to do.
There's nothing funded.
Their engineering conferences,
how would you deflect an asteroid?
Okay,
how would you destroy one?
And if we see one way and it's calming 100%,
just kiss your ass goodbye.
That's right.
We would,
we would have the power to tell you when you would die and what part of earthy
would hit.
So there's people that have very delusional ideas about what we can and can't do
with asteroids.
And that drives me crazy.
No,
it's not that we know how to do the,
I've seen the engineering plans,
they look very good,
but there's nothing in place,
right?
There's project sentinel,
you can look it up.
That is,
has tasked themselves with organizing world governments to protect earth from
species killing asteroids.
And you need the world because you don't know in advance until it's discovered
what part of earth it's going to hit.
And if it's going to hit in the Indian Ocean and Indian,
if,
um,
the surrounding regions don't have a space program or are there countries that
do have a space program going to sit idle?
No.
What you want to do is you want to have a fund and every country pipes in a
little bit of their GDP and then or,
or whatever,
uh,
um,
you know,
do you measure it however you want it?
Whatever you think is fair,
do it the way,
uh,
the way the UN does it.
Okay.
So there's attacks of the world relative to your wealth and then that money pays
to save the world.
When we find such an asteroid that that's how you get the Sentinel Project
Sentinel is,
is uh,
has thought this through.
So if there were engineers and scientists ample time,
there's possibility,
there's a possibility that they could actually implement some of these plants.
It's all about how much time you have.
Because what you want to do is go out and nudge it a little bit,
a little bit.
You just have to give it a sideways velocity relative to its path towards earth.
If you do that early enough,
the s the sideways velocity sort of accumulate like a ship turning slightly over
the ocean of the course of time,
it'll deviate quite a bit.
Correct.
So that angle grows.
I mean it's the same angle,
but the,
it spreads out and it's the,
the ocean example is perfect.
There's a perfect analogy.
So if you do that early enough,
you do it enough so that it misses earth and it's still out there to harm you in
another day,
but it won't render you extinct on that passage.
How much time do we need today?
Uh,
if I would say we could probably get something built in 10 years.
Oh Jeez.
What?
Neil degrasse Tyson.
Why don't you just do 10 years?
I'm looking for him and that's,
oh no.
Oh my gosh.
So it's a year.
If we have a year.
The good thing about species killing asteroids is that they're large and
visible.
What about city Killen ones?
Them talkers slip through.
Yeah,
they'll slip through.
Yeah.
But most of earth's surface is not city,
so it'll probably hit the ocean or,
or land.
But yeah,
if it does,
it would take out a city.
The whole city gone.
Yeah.
Oof.
This is a branch of government part of,
I don't know if it survived the Trump changeover,
but it's uh,
it's part of a homeland security where worries about devastation to a region
where the grid is taken out as well.
So you can't bring emergency services that bring are the food,
water,
medicines,
uh,
any other form of transportation or communication.
How much thought is there to putting in a more robust grid?
Uh,
yeah,
what you would need is,
that's,
that's a good point.
So you need a grid that can sort of,
uh,
rewire itself rapidly to then bring power to a region,
that that's what you would need.
And it would ditch sort of doing that now making a grid,
sort of a lightening proof,
you know,
a power surge proof.
I grew up in New York City where there were a couple of very famous blackouts
when in 1966 and other,
and when was it?
1978,
I think.
And it was like,
Whoa,
how should this,
how is this even allowed?
You don't have a backup plan.
Yeah.
You don't have a way to rewire this to redirect the electricity.
So yeah,
you'd need that and you'd want that.
And I thought the new grid is supposed to have those kinds of protections built
into it,
but I don't know enough about it to comment
it all it take is one one impact.
Oh yeah,
one big one.
Yeah.
It takes out the grid.
And what do you have solar power you place?
Uh,
we just put in Pat Pat solar panels.
Yeah.
You live in a place that's ever seen and we have a place in the country escape
to,
yeah.
It's a good move to have the escape spot.
Yeah.
You have a place in upstate New York?
No,
no,
it's on long island.
Yeah.
I used to think of it as an escape because we thought of getting it after
September 11th.
Yeah.
Got It.
And Oh,
three Oh two,
something like that.
But,
um,
now it's just a good place for me to refuel and through a lot of good writing
there and this sort of thing.
Look out for ticks and know,
oh my God.
Long islands overwhelmed with Lyme disease.
They got a new tick apparently that prevents you from eating meat,
Vegetarians,
bread that
it's called the lone star tick and it prevents you from eating the meat of
mammals.
Yes.
Makes you allergic to Alpha galactose.
Is that what it is?
It's Alpha Gow than another great radio lab podcast.
I detailed I think the vegans and the Vegetarians,
I think that,
yeah,
I think that he's still your fish.
Yeah.
Chicken not eat a mammal.
Just can't eat red meat.
It's something in red meat.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
that's one of the challenges,
right?
But goddamn ticks.
Yeah.
They are everywhere.
And we looked at it the other day.
There's a,
cause I have quite a few friends that have Lyme disease and it's something you
do keep for life.
And,
uh,
quite a few friends,
like seven or eight I think at this point that have devastating Lyme disease.
And it's all east coast people.
They're making love in the brush.
Like what are they doing walking around going for a hike,
you know?
I see it.
Yeah.
I'm a city person.
So even though I moved to the country,
I go for a hike on my deck.
You don't go anywhere?
No,
no.
Sit back.
Just look out pool on the deck.
But you're out there and the gorgeous country,
don't you want to go wander around a little bit?
No,
no.
It's honestly not a thought.
My wife was from Alaska has those thoughts all the time,
but the power of ticks overwhelms her power of curiosity.
Those are powerful people in Alaska.
That's a different type of,
you know,
their,
their bread differently about their strong,
those people can survive and they have a sentence to unity up there.
It's really interesting that unity I think comes from the fact that they're all
in the same risk factors together.
Yup.
And if the,
if you and I have the same things that can kill us,
that makes us friends.